[Music]
hey neil
i got another one for you you know these
right these never end
you know good i got another one it's a
good thing that they're going on people
love these so i thought maybe we'd talk
about um
hot and cold all right hot and cold hot
and cold so we're discussing my marriage
what's happening okay
what is going hot and cold so a couple
of things
you realize there's no real upper limit
to how hot you can make something right
in fact the early universe was like
trillions of degrees you just can
keep going if you concentrate enough
energy into a small enough volume
you can just keep increasing the
temperature essentially without limit
wow but you can only do that because
such a thing
as heat exists you can just keep adding
more heat okay
all right if you have something right
have more always pile it on
pile it on okay so now
if heat exists and cold does not exist
then what happens when you just start
taking away the heat so wait a minute
are we defining is
the definition of cold the absence of
heat let me just
yes yes okay okay yes
so i got heat i can add as much of it as
i want but if i start taking it away
the temperature begins to drop right
okay so now there comes a point the heat
energy i should
say so there comes a point as you keep
removing it
right where then there's no heat left
to remove right okay
and there's a guy named lord kelvin a
physicist
who let me hear you imitate the peerage
of
of course lord kell
indeed today i believe i shall endeavor
to find out
exactly what happens when i remove
heat so he he
explored what would happen if you remove
all the heat from something
if you remove all the heat what
temperature should you call that
um i would say the no heat temperature
give a number to it what number would it
be zero zero fine
so he created a brand new temperature
scale where
where there is no heat it is zero smart
therefore there can be no negative
temperatures on his scale
nice that there it is so that's called
the absolute temperature scale
the kelvin scale so
that's the scale we use in science and
in engineering typically now wait a
minute so here's what i'm
curious though uh
if if there is no heat at all
first of all you have to go someplace
where there is
no heat or created yes oh
okay so now that's my next question how
do you create a place where there is no
heat
that's everywhere on earth there's no
there's heat that's really hard to do
it turns out and so in fact initially it
was sort of a theoretical limit
of you sort of approach it
asymptotically
never actually reaching that point but
i'll get back to that in a minute
so the celsius scale named after anders
celsius
which put 100 degrees at boiling water
zero degrees at freezing water and
everything else
came along the way there because to him
why not put zero at freezing water but
of course you can be colder than that
therefore you got to introduce negative
temperature right okay so
so so the kelvin scale was developed
after the celsius scale
celsius scale was originally or commonly
is also called the centigrade
centigrades
centi as in 100 right a degree is a
hundredth of the
0 to 100 from boiling to freezing to
boiling
so this celsius gap already existed so
he said let me not rock the boat
let me put zero at the coldest point but
have each interval of temperature
be the same as the celsius scale okay
okay so no no conversions you just
subtract
yeah basically yeah yeah and and then
before you know it you're you're really
measuring kelvin in terms of self
celsius yes using this celsius unit
right so
if you so you can now ask what
temperature is absolute zero
on the celsius scale gotcha you can do
that
so you go below zero and it's way colder
than freezing water you just keep going
and going and going and it's 273 degrees
below zero on the celsius scale so minus
273
celsius is zero degrees kelvin absolute
zero and that's all you got to do
that's so cool so there we have absolute
zero so now the question is how do you
get there
okay right and so it's all about
the removal of of thermal energy what is
thermal energy
it's the vibration of particles gotcha
all right
so if you have some thing that has a
higher temperature than some other thing
and you go in and measure the particles
and how they're moving they're vibrating
faster
gotcha okay so temperature is the
average kinetic energy of vibrating
particles in any substance at all
okay so everything vibrates if you have
a solid
hunk of iron right does it have
temperature yes then you get in there
and you'll see the
the iron atoms are vibrating okay within
whatever lattice they're located
if they're vibrating now there's another
layer here i'm not going to get into but
i will say it
okay all the particles especially in a
gas all the particles are not vibrating
at the same rate some are faster than
others some are slower than others
okay and there's and and the
distribution of these
has it has a name it's called a
maxwellian distribution named after
james clark maxwell
who studied the distribution of the
vibration of particles depending what
temperature they were
right but as you raise the temperature
all the vibratory speeds get higher
there you go okay okay so that so
it's why for example when you're boiling
water and some water evaporates off the
top
how come the entire pot doesn't
evaporate all at once right
okay only the fastest moving particles
will vibrate
we'll we'll jump out okay at any given
moment it's only the fastest ones
getting out
and all the rest are still in there and
then others populate the fast zone and
then they
get out so there's a range of speeds
over which the particles vibrate
now a a subtle and very physically point
i have to make
heat energy is the total energy carried
by all the particles
that's it okay the total energy that
makes sense the
temperature however is the average
kinetic energy
of the particles okay so in other words
a cup of coffee
hot coffee in the morning is hotter than
the ocean however the ocean has more
total energy in it
right because it's the total sum of all
the particles so it's total sum of all
the particles so i just want to
distinguish
sort of temperature and and and
and thermal energy there's a distinction
between those two
that makes sense okay so let's get back
to kelvin
all right so how do i make something
colder so what i have to do is i need
something else next to it that can take
the heat away
okay i put food in your refrigerator
the air around the food is colder than
the food
has less heat energy than your food does
so it's taking the heat energy from it
okay then what then what does it do with
it it goes through your
coils in the back of the refrigerator
and then if you ever hang out in the
back your refrigerator it's hot there
absolutely that heat used to be in the
food that you put in it
right that's where that came from see
now what we should do
instead of having an oven beneath our
stove we should have a refrigerator and
use the heat
to cook on top and that would make sense
it doesn't get that hot i don't know
what you put in your refrigerator
so so so it means you need something
colder something with sort of less heat
energy
attached to the one that has more so
that it can basically
extract it well let's keep doing this
and you keep doing let's get down to
like you know 100 degrees kelvin and 50
degrees kelvin and 10 degrees calm
i keep doing this and i'm at like one
degree kelvin i need something colder
than that
i i need something colder to pull away
that heat right
but if i always need something colder
how am i ever going to get to zero
yes this is the challenge
this is the challenge okay so now it
turns out you can take a gas
which is vibrating okay at a certain
rate and expand it
and that will slow down the vibration of
the particles and the gas will cool
you have to put energy to do that but
you can that you can do that by the way
that's how compressors work point is
point is um you can
make things colder a gas holder by
expanding it
you just keep doing this okay you keep
doing it so
we we can get to within like micro
degrees of absolute zero
but you can never philosophically and
theoretically you can never
actually get to absolute zero for this
reason
right because you need something
you can get like arbitrarily close now
there's another problem
uh oh okay okay there's another problem
okay quantum physics takes over
and in quantum physics one of the tenets
is
you can never know precisely
where anything about anything
i believe i read that that that is
quantum physics
you can never know anything about
anything
it's not that bad okay the point is
it means in quantum physics nothing is
ever stationary
so it means there's a entire branch of
physics that says you may
try to stop the motion of this particle
but you will never succeed because
there's a
quantum vibration that goes on
no matter how much heat you've taken out
and this is quantum physics taking over
so the point is not only is there sort
of
a classical physical limit to reaching
absolute zero
there's a quantum limit that prevents it
entirely
wow and so there it is a little bit
more probably more than you care to know
about absolute zero no that's
fascinating stuff that's very cool
because you hear about i mean
listen everybody learns about absolute
zero in school but you don't
learn about it to the extent that not to
the extent
let me add one other thing go ahead okay
so this is this is just so cool
all right but i'll let you to be the
judge all right all right as a particle
slows down you've you've heard in
quantum physics you can have wave and
particle duality you might have heard
about it that's
light but of course okay i believe i
believe lord
kelvin
this is actually um schrodinger
showed us that you can have a particle
that also functions as a wave now here's
the thing
as you slow down the particle right
the wave associated with it gets longer
ah okay cool now watch what happens
if you have a system of particles
and you begin to slow them down
and their waves become longer there's a
point where
all their waves match up
and the material becomes a coherent
functioning new state of matter
really and it's called bose-einstein
condensate
and so this was predicted that if you
froze something
enough these free particles froze them
enough and there they are doing their
own thing
doing their own vibratory dance if you
get it cold enough
all of the wavelengths will begin to
match and then
the entire substance will function as
though it's one object
nice it's a whole new state and behavior
of matter
and it happens at those very cold
temperatures below one degree
kelvin so you can shape shift matter
yes yes yes i love that shape shifting
it
yes and it all happens together and you
warm it up then it goes back to you know
what it's like it's like birds that
flock
right they come down and then they're
pecking away separately and then
they start flying then they all go
together yeah that movie scared the hell
out of it
exactly yes
so that's a it's a bad analogy but it's
visually similar
yeah okay it's not physically similar
just visually similar
wow so cool things happen at low temp
you get super conducting fluids
you get super supe you get super you
know what super fluidity is
uh when you cool something enough and
once again you get these wavelengths
that match up
and if it's in a fluid state you can
plunge your hand
through the fluid and the fluid just
parts in front of your hand and there is
no
resistance to moving through the liquid
wow it's called a this superfluid
another quantum state that arises then
you have superconductivity
where there's no resistance to to the
current of electricity
so if you filled a tube with super fluid
and there's zero resistance correct you
could
actually travel in that tube at enormous
speeds
yeah you travel faster than the speed of
sound in the
the normal speed of sound in a liquid
that's correct yes oh
cool yeah it's very very cool
and and so it's interesting imagine
being a funder
and some physicist says i want to play
with cold temperatures and see what's
the point of that what are you going to
learn
it's just going to get cold and then you
realize that matter behaves completely
differently under those conditions
and different matter behaves differently
from other matter and so
it is it's an extraordinary new place to
visit
in the world of physics and who ordered
that who would have thought that this
would
was laying there waiting to be
discovered but it was
that's amazing and all i can say is this
uh
as a black man i do not like the cold
but you have just changed my entire
outlook on it
because you want to get some of that
super fluid
[Laughter]
oh and also the kelvin as a unit of
temperature has been elevated
to be its own unit without even having
to mention the word degree
it's just the kelvin well no it's not
even the
it's uh what's the temperature 29 kelvin
kelvins that's right
oh kelvin and it is elevated so high
that it's now a lowercase k
wow that's how you know you're bad but
that's what you know you made it
right what's that it's not kelvin
degrees degrees kelvin
kelvins it's and you know who else has
that newton their newtons is a unit of
of uh force
so nice all right so what would you want
to be measured and we i know we got to
go we don't but i'm gonna i just want to
end on something
weird and fun what would you want to be
measured
that would be measured in tysons oh
i got to think about that let me think
about that i don't have an answer right
yeah actually i don't want to be
remembered for anything i just want to
for me education is empowering you to
understand what it is you're talking
about with any reference back to me
at all and that but thereby you take
ownership of your own enlightenment
see that's too damn noble see i want you
to remember me
okay we'll work on what what what unit
will be called the nice
all right dude we got to call it quits
there all righty more than you ever care
to know about the kelvin
at absolute zero temperature scale uh
this is
at star talk yet another explainer video
chuck always good to have you always a
pleasure as always
[Music]
you